avec plus de 6000 appareils vendus dans
une centaine de pays des cinq continents
l'aérospatiale marignane est aujourd'hui
la capitale mondiale de l'hélicoptère un
des secrets de cette extraordinaire
réussite peut se résumer en deux chiffes
un dixième des 6000 employés travaillent
au bureau d'études et 2% du chiffre
d'affaires sont affectés à la recherche
cette chaîne de montage de l'écureuil et
la plus moderne d'europe
chaque équipe suivant l'assemblage d'un
hélicoptère du début jusqu'à la fin
ici on construit indifféremment les
écureuils mono et du turbine les
successeurs moderne de la célèbre
famille des alouettes à marignane les
clients potentiels se succèdent sur les
chaînes
ici un acheteur japonais se fait
expliquer par le chef du service de
livraison tous les détails techniques de
sa nouvelle acquisition
c'est le dernier stade des négociations
qui ont souvent commencé plusieurs mois
auparavant
au lieu de se limiter à de simples
transactions commerciales l'aérospatiale
hélicoptère s'est depuis longtemps
résolument tourné vers une véritable
politique de coopération pour ne prendre
qu'un seul exemple une trentaine de
chinois vivent en permanence à marignane
apprenant les secrets de la fabrication
ici là dauphins dont la chine a acheté
il ya un an
la licence de construction pour 50
machines le jour où nous étions à
marignane ont discuté contrat avec le
colonel marquez des forces aériennes
brésiliennes pour l'acquisition de 50 à
60 super puma et ont signé également
avec l'inde un nouveau compromis
commercial
au centre de cette politique tournée
vers l'exploitation françois le grand le
patron la division hélicoptères ça
consiste à avoir une technologie très
avancée à avoir des produits bien
adaptés au marché aussi bien en marche
et militaires pour marché civil qui est
maintenant le marché qui se développe
beaucoup très vite et il fallait aussi
avoir un système de commercialisation de
diffusion de nos produits de support
après vente qui soit adaptée à cette
vocation mondiale et ça nous avons
beaucoup travaillé là dessus
en particulier nous avons établi et
quelques années une filiale aux états
unis qui comporte actuellement 600
personnes qui est installée près de
dallas au lieu de se contenter des 20%
du marché américain d'ores et déjà
conquis l'aérospatiale est bien décidé à
aller encore plus loin
à l'occasion de ce 34e salon
international de l'aéronautique du
bourget les responsables de la firme de
marignane viennent de franchir un
nouveau pas désormais ils proposent à
leur clientèle au travers d'une société
filiale de services de véritables
contrats de formation de pilote et le
mécanicien d'hélicoptère
en d'autres mots achetés nus
l'hélicoptère nous occupons du reste
une formule qui devrait tenter certains
nouveaux clients du tiers-monde et
d'ailleurs